[Musique]
au sommet d'une montagne lointaine une
belle jeune femme us de ses talents de
pâtissière de sculptrice et de
couturière pour élaborer des douceurs
alléchante elle a l'art de révéler la
beauté ténébreuse de chacune de ses
oeuvres qu'elles partagent ensuite avec
nous pendant les créatures monstrueuses
qu'elle a beaucoup lit sous son toit
je ne sais plus à quand remonte votre
dernier repas normal tu appelle ça un
repas normal c'est spectaculaire manque
de sucre quand elle aura refroidi
j'ai sculpteur est un visage je me sers
d'une poche remplie de glaçage au je
vois je peux t'aider
bon
une jolie petite princesse ne m'attend
pas
c'est notre maison toutes les créatures
étranges et inhabituelles sont les
bienvenus et en sécurité
rejoignez nous dans l'univers
délicieusement macabre des curieuses
création de christine mcconnell je pense
qu'il fallait tout fait ou alors connaît
bien la de gentillesse ça prend beaucoup
trop de temps